[Music]
[Applause]
well hello friends thank you for uh
choosing to be with us for this half
hour program I'd like to know we
appreciate uh you being with us we also
appreciate uh your support of Secrets
unsealed through donations and
especially through your prayers that the
Lord will use this to reach many many
who are in the valley of decision who
are looking for answers to their
questions uh once again thank you for
being with us uh if you want to send us
your questions you'll see the address on
the screen
tvsm tv.org once again TVM tv.org
we'd be delighted to get your questions
uh we'll do the research uh some
questions are answerable others are not
uh some questions we give our best uh
estimation of what would be beneficial
because there's no clear Revelation from
the Lord but be assured that we don't
answer every anything off the cuff we do
our research and we provide the best
information that is available uh I'd
like to um introduce to you um uh David
Salazar who is uh in charge of our
Spanish work here at secrets on seal and
some TV uh very efficient uh it's a
blessing to have him here and his um
Family nearby his wife does children's
stories sometimes for us among other
things uh thank you Pastor for being
with us and uh maybe you could mention
the address where people can send us
your questions um absolutely Pastor you
know it is always a blessing to relase
you know spend time with you here in
this program that it's a favorite for
many people around the world we have met
many people who are always asking us or
actually Thanking us for the program of
a like to know and they you can send the
address they can send the questions to
TV atam tv.org uh where they can ask and
we'll promise you we'll promise our
viewers that we will be able to answer
them according to uh the time that we
get to them so we have to have a little
of patience we ask for Pati as you may
be aware that we have a lot of questions
in in in you know in store so yes but
all right so uh last time we were
answering the questions from Andre right
uh who was writing from
Romania and we're very thankful that we
have H viewers in Romania and we had
covered uh three of the questions but
there were still two yes that we didn't
answer so why don't we go to question
number four right let's uh before we
answer this question Pastor let's pray
as we know that we always do this before
we open God's word and we have to let do
that praise the Lord let's pray Heavenly
Father we thank you Lord for allowing us
to come to you once again and to seek
the wisdom that comes from up high we
know that we in ourselves are not of any
knowledge or any authority to say
anything that really uh can give Clarity
to people but we know that through the
power of the Holy Spirit and through
your word we can be instruments in
pointing people to you and bringing them
the truth of your word so we pray that
you will be uh with us and use us so
that we may have this experience of
having spent time with you and having
heard from your word we pray this in
Jesus name amen amen all right Pastor so
the questions like you mentioned from
Andre was two questions that are pending
and we'll right Jump Right In the
question that he has the fourth question
he had was the following he says why did
Jesus eat meat uh he uh he cites Luke
24:42 and 43 and says why did Jesus eat
meat if this type of diet is not part of
God's original plan if God wants
Humanity to return to the original diet
presented in Genesis 139 why didn't
Jesus choose to set an example in this
matter he now he Andre says I am now
vegan and I'm convinced that this is a
diet that God's people should follow but
I have received such arguments against
hell reform even from church members MH
so this is a question that I I know that
many people may have you know and and
this argument of Christ eating meat is a
lot of times the argument people say you
know I don't see a reason why I need to
give up meat you know if he didn't give
it up meat why should I and he's you
know he has this question or or
wondering what what can we say to this
well they use that as an
excuse you know they justify
uh not following a vegan diet by by
Jesus eating fish yeah uh now it Bears
noting that Jesus did not
disobey Hebrew ritual law right because
God had permitted uh the Jews to eat
clean Meats but there were prescriptions
that needed to be followed right number
one they could the meat could not have
fat mhm and number two they could not
eat the blood mhm and and so Jesus did
not violate any of the laws that God
gave through Moses to the children of
Israel um Jesus obviously according to
this did eat fish right uh which is
probably the least
objectionable uh meat that can be
partaken of uh Jesus was part of his
culture and in that culture uh you know
eating uh fish was common I mean his
disciples many of his disciples were
fishermen right and uh and so uh Jesus
simply uh lived as the people of of the
culture of that day it Bears noting
however that eating meat at that time
was totally different than eating
meeting meat today right uh 2,000 years
have passed and the animal world is sick
yes and they inject hormones into them
growth hormones and and uh
you know the the environment has all
kinds of
diseases uh and so uh you know eating
meat at the market today or even fish
filled with Mercury by the way uh is not
the same as eating fish from the Sea of
Galilee in the times of Christ
absolutely pastor and and you know it's
important to know that uh find trying to
find an excuse for a behavior that is of
of last of the flesh you know whether
you know I enjoy meat or I enjoy uh
anything that it's contrary to God's
word I will find excuses people can find
excuses to continue their evil habits
but as you have said Christ clearly ate
according to the LW of the ritical you
know or or the levitical ways of eating
and cleaning you know having the clean
animals only and um today many people
who eat meat even sadly church members
do not follow any of those rules you
know they buy the meats from any type of
place where blood fat all is part of
that and so if we really want to be like
Christ well they should follow like
Christ did you know and so technically
there's not really a sin we cannot say
that it's a sin if you eat a clean meat
according to the rules said in the Bible
but if you do eat meat without those
rules then you are committ Abomination
even the blood was an Abomination before
the Lord so we have that evidence now as
you mentioned the time has changed and
spirit prophecy clearly helps us
understand this in the book Child
Guidance page 382 she says the following
flesh was never the best food but its
use is now doubly objectionable
objectionable since these Sease in
animals is so rapidly increasing those
who use flesh Foods little know what
they're eating often they could see the
animals when living and know the quality
of the meat they eat they will turn from
it with loathing people are continually
eating flesh that is filled with
tuberculose and cancerous germs and so
this is what the Lord revealed to her to
to the Ser of the Lord to understand
that the time today to eat meat it's
it's really you know not very smart it's
not safe anymore compared to the times
of Jesus the bottom line is that when
circumstances change change right God uh
changes his counsel right
for example you know uh with regards to
eating flesh food uh the the animal
world is sick today yes and of course
when they prepare the the meat to go to
market uh you know you have growth
hormones that are injected and you have
uh you know pesticides that the cows are
eating the are eating the grass and the
and the hay and everything that has been
treated with pesticides um you know the
animal world is going to be different
than it was back then um some people say
well you know uh God allowed Israel to
eat clean meats and therefore uh you
know that applies today also but when
circumstances change yeah God changes
his counsel right back then it was safe
to eat in an agrarian society it was
safe to eat meat clean meat of course
with the prescriptions that it be kosher
that it not have fat and not have blood
right but circumstances have changed so
what God permitted in the past yeah if
he permitted it today he would be going
against his own principles because he
would be saying well you know once I
promised you could eat clean meats and
so you can eat them now even if they're
filled with growth hormones even if
they're filled with diseases because I
said once you could eat it now you can
eat it as well uh God changes his
counsel according to the change in
circumstances not his Ten Commandment
Laws but uh when circumstances change
yeah God changes his counil to be in
harmony with his principles amen amen
and I think Pastor you know as you
mentioned the the fact is that people
have to learn that God is now um giving
us Clarity of of of light in this regard
because he wants to prepare his people
to understand the truths to be able to
have a clearer mind and to have a
healthier lifestyle as well we see the
results of of of continuing these habits
of eating based on taste only or what
you know we want instead of what's
healthy for us and I believe that God is
preparing our people and things has
changed to prepare us from eternity and
if we want to be in heaven and the Lord
says to me today through the inspiration
through the you Spirit prophecy that
it's best to not longer eat meat I
should comply happily to that because it
really is a preparation for what in
heaven will be like we're not going to
be eating meat in heaven there's going
be no dead animals not killing nothing
of that sort so it's it's a privilege we
have now to kind of start preparing our
taste bus even from you know lasting
after the fleshly things or the fleshly
meats but actually being a novel and be
more Ain to what the Springs of Heaven
is going to be like bottom line we have
much more light today yes much more
light from the spirit of Prophecy much
more light from uh even going to Google
and seeing what H is happening with the
meat market right so you know what might
have been excusable in the past without
all the information now is not
absolutely because circumstances have
changed the animal world is a lot sicker
than it used to be amen all right the
next question Pastor from Andre is a
question five uh that he had and we're
answering um you know today the second
question he says how can we reconcile
the six commandment with Samuel 1st
Samuel 15:3 and other examples in the
Bible where God asked his people to
destroy cities or tribes in the context
of the execution of the Divine judgment
what did children and infants do wrong
so he's of course uh uh commenting on
the or looking at 1st Samuel 15:3 where
the Lord instructed King Saul to follow
the Commandment of of of or or through
Samuel to King Saul to destroy amak
amalekites completely not leave children
babies nothing and so how can we
reconciled the sixth commandment of God
shall not you know that shall not kill
with this commandment with this incident
okay uh the answer is that uh this would
be an anticipated execution of judgment
against these nations and against these
cities you know I don't hear anyone
complain about fire descending and
consuming Sodom and gomorah God did that
right I don't find anyone complaining
about God uh sending a flood yeah to
destroy the anti- deluvian world God did
that right but when it comes to God
telling Israel to do it for him they
immediately have a problem and say how
could God do that yeah the fact is that
not only do individuals commit the
unpardonable sin cities commit the
unpardonable sin right Nations commit
the unpardonable sin uh you know uh the
the iniquity of the amorites was not
full
when Israel entered uh when God spoke to
Abraham yeah but in the times when
Israel entered the promised land The
amorites Who resisted and tried to keep
Israel from entering the promised land
they had gone beyond the point of no
return and uh the same is true of of all
of the civilizations that God uh told
Israel to destroy they had committed
corporately the unpardonable sin right
and so only God knows when a
civilization has committed the
unpardonable sin yeah uh because God is
is able to read all the circumstances
he's the judge uh but we have no right
to do that because we don't have that
knowledge that God has right and and
also you know adding to that Pastor bour
you know the fact is that the execution
of God through the children of Israel as
you mentioned for his judgment was not
an uh personal decision of the people of
God to go and kill individuals this is a
judgment that God used to destroy this
culture or he wanted them to destroy
this culture because the influence their
their corruption was to the core now uh
it's not the same thing as as uh when
you know God does present several times
in the Bible that he will execute
judgment meaning killing or destroying
iniquity and sin uh the ver the the
actual commandment is th shall not
commit murder that shall not kill with
intention of personal gain but if God
decides to destroy something he's not
going against his law he's just
executing the Judgment it's part of the
aspect of his Justice his character
iniquity if he will allow iniquity to
continue then well it will never stop
from growing like cancers so he has to
cut make a decision and Destroy and and
cut that iniquity that's building up so
this is not the same as killing as
murdering individual is there any
objection for example to God reigning
fire from heaven to consume the wicked
after the Millennium no no that is not
murder you cannot Define that as murder
God doesn't go around killing people
right God executes judgment and that
judgment is based on people's choice
right the people choose to be outside
the holy city after the Millennium right
they they actually chose during their
lifetime uh that they were going to be
outside the holy city is God to blame
for that God said I place before you
life and death you choose whether you
want life or whether you want death and
uh with regards to the close of
probation when probation
closes every case is decided and no
matter if God allowed a thousand years
more to go by yeah nobody would change
their side right everybody would stay
with the choice that they made and God
knows that only God knows when that
takes place now uh there are three
things that we need to take into account
number one God provides great light to a
civilization God had provided great
light to to Sodom and Gomorrah of course
I mean Abraham just with with a few men
went back and and and got everything
back that had been taken by those by
those tribes uh you know Abraham raised
an altar every place he went in honor of
the true God they had received abundant
light and yet they slighted the light
they wanted to commit homosexual
relations with the angels in the house
of lot they had gone beyond the point of
no return Before the Flood God gave
great light through Noah and they had
the option of entering the ark and be
saved they decided they didn't want to
go into the ark so they chose
destruction they destroyed themselves
God simply executed their choice exactly
and and so uh God provides great light
the light is
rejected and therefore God executes
judgment but God doesn't execute
judgment without people having the
knowledge of what they're supposed to do
now in the Book of Revelation it speaks
about the whole Earth being lightened
with the glory of God which is known as
the loud cry Angel the fourth angel of
Revelation chapter 18 the whole world is
going to be filled with the glory of God
with the message of God for the end
times concerning the Sabbath what is
most of the world going to do reject it
they're going to reject it and therefore
who is responsible for the destruction
themselves those reject let me ask you
this who was responsible for the
destruction of Jerusalem yeah the Jewish
wasn't God no of course the nation chose
made their choice to reject Christ and
therefore they uh they receive the
consequences of their own choice I'd
like to recommend a book
uh it's written by Steve Walberg it's
called the character of God controversy
it's carried by Secrets unsealed or you
can get it from White House media which
is his uh Ministry it's an excellent
book on all of these cases where God
tells Israel to destroy and uh you know
where God destroys Sodom and gomorah
where Aza you remember Aza you know he
touched the ark and he dropped dead
right you know how
he wanted to save the ark I mean what
guilt does God have an anas and saf
right he mentions all of these cases in
the book and it's just really really
well written and provides a much broader
answer than we can on this program right
and and you know Pastor thinking about
this you know one of the things that a
lot of people make the argument is well
what about the infants the babies as
he's asking this question what about
them babies and infants that we call
humanly speaking they're innocent
they're they're perfect they don't have
any guilt but uh we know that
unfortunately as you mentioned society
and cultures and cities and governments
can can commit corporately the unable
sin yes and so uh you know but what we
can know for sure and I think that the
Bible gives us this evidence that if one
family out of that whole city that whole
culture repents you know God will give
them a way out and they will save them
for example the the in the case of
Jericho you have an example there in
Rahab who was a harlot but she feared
God she opened the door to the to the
two spies and the Lord I mean destroyed
every single one of the city of Jericho
except her and her family were saved
because of her act of you know fearing
the Lord and fearing the children of
Israel as God's people so we can see
that if if for example the execution was
made or the order was made to destroy
every single amalaka right well if there
was a one Godly family they would you
know the Lord would spare them and so we
have to know that God is just and he
will not destroy the Wicked with the
innocent as he mentioned uh you know or
as Abraham asked and Begg from the Lord
you know interceding for S and gomorra
so I think that's important to know that
those infants those babies if they're
destroyed is because their parents their
family their culture is already in that
point of not return however if there was
a family and individual a person you
know that was uh repented and and that
did not have the opportunity to hear and
that heard the the truth God will you
know will be just with them as well and
he will not just you know destroy people
just for the sake of destroying
furthermore the Tendencies and
inclinations of the parents is
transmitted to the children right so so
those children even the infants receive
the result of the inheritance of the
parents yeah and what would happen in
the course of time is that they would
most likely continue uh promoting the
sins of their parents and they would
once again bring about the same problem
that existed when these cities and when
these nations were destroyed right now
uh when it comes to the infants they had
not reach the age of accountability uh
so what is going to happen with them if
they didn't reach the the the time when
they were accountable they understood
and went against light what happens to
those infants well some people say well
the Lord is going to save them uh uh you
know and but there's another view and
that is that they will be as though they
had never been in other words they're
not going to be resurrected to suffer uh
second death after the Millennium but
they simply will suffer uh the the death
that they suffered when the cities were
destroyed uh Ellen White for example
mentions the slaves uh their master was
their conscience I mean they didn't have
a conscience of their own they didn't
have any way of
differentiating good from Evil and Ellen
White says that they will be as though
they had never been they are not going
to be punished uh like the wicked are
going to be punished after the Thousand
Years and so we need to understand that
Tendencies and inclinations would have
been transmitted to the Next Generation
you would have had the same problem one
thing we can be sure of and that is that
any decision that God made we will agree
in eternity that God acted properly and
right because God is loving merciful and
just so we might look now and say why
Lord did you do it that way when we get
up there and God explains it'll make
perfect sense and we'll say thank you
Lord for doing it your way and and the
fact that of of the children of Israel
of Saul specifically in the case that he
mentions there in first Samuel do you
know his his neglection of following the
duty of the Lord that he imposed on him
almost caus the Israelites their own
life in you know Generations later
because that that that you know because
he spared the wicked King and his family
the descendants of that Wicked King
eventually almost destroyed through Aman
you know the uh the in the time of of of
Esther so it's important you know that's
interesting that uh you know a hmon yeah
was of the family exactly of one of
those that should have been destroyed
ancestors that should have been
destroyed by Saul but Saul didn't do
what go God told him to do and so there
you see that's a good example to see the
consequences of not following God's
orders and following your own wisdom
amen that's right so anyway well um very
engaging
conversation uh I trust that what we've
discussed is uh a benefit to you that uh
you will continue to do research on your
own please uh study this matter for
yourself and uh may God be with you
thank you once again for being with us
and thank you for your support through
prayer and through your financial
donations God bless hope to see you next
time
[Music]